hi everyone can you all hear me alright
I think it's time we'll just get started
here hi my name is Dave Beck burger and
we're here today to talk to give my talk
about a skeptics guide to graph
databases but before I start I kind of
want to ask a little question so here
I'm who here in the audience has heard
about what a graph databases or I've
heard of the time
excellent so most of you how many of you
have actually used one well that's
that's good I gave this talk similar
talk clashing there was two so now we're
up to about 10 or 15 how many of you
actually put something into production
with one okay we're down to about four
how many of you actually put it into
production successfully yeah we're down
to a couple so that's sort of what the
whole premise of this talk is to kind of
walk through the process of what it
actually takes to make a graph database
implementation successful so a little
bit about myself before we get started
so I've been doing this I've been doing
software development for about 20 years
every time I say that it starts to make
me feel older and older it's actually a
little more than 20 years now but I
don't want to admit how long and I've
done everything I've done a little bit
of everything I started out my actual
first job was to build embedded C
programs on top of DOS and I've done
that everything there through building
out high through building out high
performance websites most recently I've
been focused on big data problems
specifically around building high
performance low latency data platforms
and a lot of times at least part of
those data platforms has been levering
DeGraaf love Regina graph database
currently I am a Solutions Architect at
data stacks in the global graph practice
if you're not familiar with who data
stacks is we are the Apache Cassandra
people we have our own distribution of
Cassandra that integrates search
analytics and then graph on top of it
which is why I'm part of the global
graph practice there I'm also the
co-author of an upcoming book by Manning
called date graph databases in action
and if you are if you want that's my
Twitter handle up in the corner if you
tweet out during this presentation I
have five free copies I can give away at
the end doesn't have to be nice but I
would prefer it be nice so what are we
gonna talk about well we're gonna talk
about what graph debate graph databases
are just so everybody has a little bit
of a level set it seems like most people
least bit heard of them which is
and then why you should care about him
why why they're actually useful in some
cases and not in others then when she'd
use one because that's the biggest
challenge I see when I work with people
is they try to use a graph database for
the wrong use case and it just doesn't
end up working then you can learn from
my mistakes as I said I've been doing
this probably I've been working with
craft databases for about four or five
years now I've made a lot of the
mistakes that you're gonna make when you
start so learn from them
try not to me let's not try not to
repeat the same problems I did and then
last we're gonna talk a little bit about
how to make a successful project and and
how to actually make that project you go
you're working on successful or to know
if it's not going to be successful early
on so what's the graph database graph
database is a type of no sequel database
that's built on top of graph theory
so graph theory if you've ever taken a
discrete mathematics course you've
probably heard about the seven bridges
of königsberg problem well what that
really comes down to is it comes down a
graph theory basically it gives a
mathematical construct to how to
describe entities and the relationships
between them entities they describe as
vertexes which the plural is vertices or
vertex is it's actually both or correct
depending on who you ask and they're
represented most frequently by these
circles and edges represent the
relationships between vertices and
they're represented by the lines so
you'll you'll see that throughout this
and really what craft databases are all
about and they're all they're all about
handling highly connected data types
we'll talk about some examples here
coming up but really they handle this
highly connected data types in ways that
allow you to get insights into what
you're working into your data that you
can't get using other technologies so
where do they fit when I said think
about databases I think about databases
is kind of a spectrum of data complexity
there's a spectrum of data complexity
from very simple data to very complex
data and there's different databases and
data stores out there that do that work
with each type very very well simplest
one its key value store we've all
probably used these a lot of times you
use something like this for a cache in a
key value store really it's it's this is
your reaction rate asset is your dynamo
DVS they're very simple databases
there's a key and a value there's no
real relationships amongst those things
each one is atomic into itself unto
itself I should say get a little bit
more you want to get a little more
complex data you get wide column stores
these are column-oriented databases this
is like a Cassandra
Google BigTable and Apache HBase if
you're familiar with those and these
basically you really think of them as a
single database a single table in like a
relational database
they usually have rows and columns but
there's no ability to join data across
rows no ability to really do any of the
more complex connectiveness
that you get with other data stores but
they are connected in as much as the
data and a single glow is connected to
each other you get a little bit more
complex you start getting document
databases this is your MongoDB is your
as your document DB s
Couchbase is your couch TVs things of
that nature and this starts having some
connectedness in your data because each
but that connectedness is all within one
atomic document anybody here is probably
used if any of the used any no sequel
data story this is probably the one
you've most likely used and they're very
very useful but what they aren't really
great at is being able to connect
multiple documents together while most
of them have the ability to potentially
join data that join at best is pretty
weak on something like an ID and it
doesn't really it doesn't enforce any
sort of referential integrity or
anything like that then we get to what
we've probably everybody here has
probably done most of their two careers
is relational databases
you know relational databases tables
columns foreign keys this is what
probably 95% of the world runs on is the
relational database paradigm but the
thing I find funny about relational
databases is even though it has a
relation relations in the name it's
actually pretty poor it it being able to
represent relations in the data and I
say that because the only way you can
really represent relations in a data is
to link together foreign key by four you
can link together tables via foreign key
well that seems great it's a pretty weak
Association because that relationship
can't really add any value to that
connection in and of itself it's it's a
pretty anemic thing because it's just a
name you can't add any semantic value
that relationship can't have any
connectedness to it which is why when
you get down to those sorts of things
you end up with bridge tables and Link
tables inside your relational database
to really try and represent those sorts
of those sorts of rich parts of a
relationship that relational databases
don't handle and that brings us to graph
databases graph databases are all about
handling the most complex come
phlex interconnected data that is that
is exist out in the thing why is that
well that's because graphs are all built
upon relationships the essence of a
graph from both graph theory and in the
graph database world is about
relationships and the connectedness of
your data you'll hear me say this many
times but the one kind of major thing
that a graph database gives you are to
know if you want to use a graph database
is if you if the connections between
your data are as important or more
important than the data itself that's a
really strong use case for our graph
database so what a graph databases look
like well when you start with them they
look like this they look like any other
conceptual data model you go build this
is actually a conceptual data model for
Twitter you know you have a user at the
center that tweet has links to it they
have you know hashtags their sources
there's media and they're all
interconnected with one another and when
you put it into a graph database it
looks like this this is actually a real
live well not alive I should say it's a
picture of a graph database that stored
actual Twitter data in it and what you
see on the right I think it's the right
the line one huh
my right my left or not a strength of
mine is what the schema looks like one
of the things you'll really notice about
graph database is that's really
different than other databases is they
do a much better job of representing
your conceptual model in a way that
looks very similar in both the database
and in the can in the real world so I
should say they represent real world
connections much better than other
things because the database schema it
looks very much like the conceptual
model the other reason we're here to
talk about this is this graph is a hot
trend this this slide I've used this lot
this same graphic it's from DB engines
comm first for a couple of different
presentations but every single time that
line just keeps going up and up and that
lines represents the popularity change
of graph databases since 2014 graph
databases have been the most popular
trend in and databases out there what I
would say I've you know in the past
couple years and really in the past year
what I've seen isn't so much that people
are interested in graph databases it's
that enterprises are interested in graph
databases and enterprises are starting
to put significant
sources around projects that are using
graph databases and around around those
technologies is key centerpieces for
their for their platforms moving forward
but it is all just hype haha cuz the
hype is strong with this one if you you
know especially if you've been around
and you heard about graph databases the
past few years graph databases are the
perfect solution to every get database
problem out there you should just use
them for everything no I think we can
all imagine all can agree that there
isn't one tool to solve every type of
problem out there in the world but
that's kind of what graph databases have
been portrayed as if you do much
research out there you'll come across as
you'll come across this statement
everything is a graph well it's probably
true everything in the world can
probably be represented as a graph
because everything is really about
things and thinking connections between
things but what really is missing from
this statement when you start talking
about it from a technical perspective is
just because it's a graph doesn't mean
you should use a graph to solve it you
know graphs are great for certain
problems and you can use them to solve
most problems but there are usually
better technologies for a lot of
problems like I said I work in graph
consulting and I probably most of the
time probably nine times out of 10 I
work with customers to tell them not to
use a graph database to solve their
problem it was actually pretty rare I
was there with a customer last week and
actually got to tell them to use a graph
to solve their problem and it was a was
kind of a win it was something that
doesn't happen too often
so why graphs well without even telling
you what this graph is representing you
probably everyone in this room can
probably start seeing patterns in this
graph and seeing how the connections
between things start showing showing
interesting insight into what's going on
this data specifically is actually this
graphic was made by a colleague and
actually my boss dr. Denise Gosnell what
it shows is it shows the Medicare data
for the United States so some of the
federal federal healthcare spending and
it should and the vertices represent
doctors the size of the vertice
represents how much a doctor was paid
and the connections are in the line are
the edges I'm sorry represent patients
that were shared in common between
doctors so even without actually having
known that you are probably started
seeing patterns you probably started
seeing that there was a lot of shared
patients between New York and Florida
and New York and LA
and if you know anything about the US
that makes a lot of sense as far as you
know there's a lot of people that that
winter in Florida that are from New York
so but what you also probably noticed is
that there was there seems to be an
anomaly anomaly they land down there in
southern Florida those doctors seem to
be getting paid a lot more than
everybody else
well they don't they were this ended up
being part of everything it was about a
billion dollar Medicare scam one doctor
I don't remember where there was twenty
or thirty million dollars but he in a
single year he billed Medicare for
twenty or thirty million dollars which
is probably significantly more than he
actually treated patients for so this is
just an example of you know this data
was I'm sure in a relational database
somewhere and it but putting it into a
graph allowed these sort of insights to
be come to the forefront that weren't
necessarily of easily you know seen
looking at it in a columnar form you
know rows and columns aren't necessarily
going to show this sort of thing so this
is an example and what I kind of think
about graphs I kind of think about them
in two ways I think of graphs they do
two things very well the first one is
they help us solve certain problems that
we can solve with existing technologies
better and the second one is they help
us solve problems that we can't
necessarily solve with existing
technologies and we'll go through a few
examples but kind of before we do that I
wanted to talk a little bit about some
good graph use cases so graph use cases
if you go out on the web you'll find
there's a litany of different graph use
cases people will talk about first one I
kind of wanted to talk about and
something I've worked with specifically
is fraud or anomaly detection
so by anomaly detection maybe this is
something like a network intrusion
system well fraud anomaly detection uses
kind of a feature of graphs and graph
databases which really comes down to
pattern recognition one of the one of
the strengths of a graph database is the
ability to look at patterns and data and
use those patterns to basically find
anomalies for example I mean we looked
back at that last slide basically we
were able to all pretty quickly and
easily process that there was an anomaly
going on there in southern Florida and
that there were some other anomalies as
far as how connections work and that's
something that a graph works very well
to do the second use case that we see a
lot of is knowledge graphs knowledge
graphs kind of it's kind of a loaded
term there's been a variety of different
one
out there but there's kind of they kind
of fall into two buckets that I think of
I kind of think of them as like an old
old-school knowledge graph in a
new-school knowledge graph so the
old-school knowledge graph is really one
that's been around for quite a while and
it really is all about building out a
semantic understanding of a domain so
really building out connections between
you know maybe it's maybe you're a book
publisher and you and you want to put
all the words from your books into a
into a knowledge graph and then link
them together in ways to find out
they're connected and then to actually
be able to infer new connections between
things based on articles that you've
published or something like that that's
kind of the old what I think of as the
old one that one's been around for a
long time that's one's kind of had the
knowledge graph tag for many years it's
come up recently in the past few years
of what I think of as the new-school
knowledge graph which is basically it's
all about collapsing data silos inside
of an enterprise so let's say you're a
enterprise and you have you know maybe
you're a retail outlet and you have a
store you have an in-store experience an
online experience a phone customer
support and an email customer support
and each of those things probably stores
data about the interactions that a
customer has in separate databases if
you're a customer support representative
when somebody calls in wouldn't it be
very nice to be able to see every
interaction that customer has had with
you so you're able to easily and quickly
you know customize their personal
experience if you know they've already
tried these three steps you don't want
to necessarily tell them to try the same
three steps to resolve a problem well
that's really what I kind of think of as
a new-school customer knowledge graph
and that's actually an example of one of
our most common use cases we call it a
customer 360 and it's really all about
being able to quickly and accurately
personalize the experience by taking
those data silos and connecting them
together we don't necessarily bring in
the data but we connect them together
we're not necessarily a system of record
for that information but we bring in
that data and show and give give
applications and customers the ability
to kind of our applications and in
people the ability to quickly see that
holistic view of a customer to really
create business value by driving a
better user experience which is really
in the end what most applications are
all about is making that customer
experience seamless recommendation
engines recommendation engines are a bit
of an interesting one
and I say they're a bit of an
interesting one because they're one
that's all often
as a great graph use case my experience
is not really they work you can build a
recommendation engine using a graph and
as long as you don't have a lot of
products or a lot of people it tends to
work very well my experience is they
don't tend to scale as well as one would
really hope there's usually better
options out there by doing something
maybe you need to put some machine
learning on it to pre generate
recommendations for different products
or for different cohorts of people in
order to do it but trying to do it in
real time tends to not scale as well as
everybody would everybody kind of hyped
up that it would Network an asset
monitoring network an asset monitoring
isn't kind of drives to another one of
the really fundamental features of graph
databases which is what's known as an
unbounded hierarchy so you have a
network that network contains that or
you know you have a network and you want
to basically find a single points of
failure in your network so if you use a
graph to to model this you have to think
about it well you have a network switch
well that's connected to I don't know a
number of different other switches that
are connected to a number of different
others which is another of other
switches down down to an unknown number
so that is a really complex problem to
try and model because you don't know how
many levels deep it goes and you don't
know how wide those each of those levels
are so if you wanted to do that in
something like a sequel server database
and you wanted to find ok we're given if
this router fails give give me a list of
everything else that's gonna fail that'd
be a really hard and complex recursive
query you'd have to write on a graph
data or on a sequel server database to
actually make that happen
the other hand that's the sort of thing
based on some of the data structures
that that graph database is used which
we'll talk about here in a few minutes
that actually are up that graph
databases are optimized to answer those
sorts of questions I I worked in a
previous life I actually worked at a
company that did family trees we build
out a family tree set I was a chief
Software Architect for them and we used
a graph database to basically model our
family trees and it was exactly this
unbounded hierarchy because you know we
would have people that would have family
trees that would have two people in them
or one person whom we had one person
that had a quarter million people in
their family tree so who is really hard
to say to give any sort of predictable
analytics out of our predictable time
out of a out of our sequel server
database to be able to answer those sort
of things we were able to you know by
optimizing it to use a graph we were
able to take the times from day
basically seconds to timeouts to load
those graphs to load those family trees
down to sub second to a few seconds
depending on the size of the trees
identity and access management this is
one that when I started working in graph
databases it didn't make any sense to me
why you would want to use something like
a graph to model an identity and access
management sort of problem but if you
start to think about it what is an
identity and access management problem
so let's say I want to find out who has
permissions on a folder well to find out
who I have who has permissions on a
folder I have to go find out every
potential group that has permissions on
a folder everybody in that group and
then every other overlain permission
those people have potentially on that
folder because you might have been given
access in a group and then denied access
is a specific user trying to build out
that graph and be able to quickly and
easily figure out who has access to what
is actually Oh graph use case we're
seeing more and more social networks
social networks are probably like the
classic graph use case this is your
linkedin's your Facebook's this is I
want to find people that follow you know
people that followed me also followed
this person or you know you know if you
know this people person you might know
this person I think this one we've
probably all seen and probably are and
we're probably all on Twitter and or
LinkedIn so we've probably all seen this
problem in real life and in real use the
last one I wanted to touch on was
machine learning machine learning is a
very interesting graph use case because
I mean I'm not a machine learning expert
so you know I may not this one statement
may be not completely correct but as far
as I know there isn't a machine learning
algorithm out there at least none of the
common ones that takes a graph as an
input the irony being if you look at a
lot of them especially something like a
neural network what it's doing under the
covers is its building out a graph as
part of its part of its model that it
does but where machine learning and
graphs really do start to overlay is
when you can start using some of the
features of the graph to be able to add
them as input parameters into a feature
set so maybe you want to use something
that there's a there's a concept called
a triangle count that shows how similar
things are or the distance between two
items things like that you can use those
as input features into a feature set in
for machine learning and the other one
we see is the ability graphs have to be
able to do unsupervised
classification based on structure and
using within graphs you can do things
that help find things like clusters of
data or influence of data based on how
that graph how that specific vertex is
associated with other vertexes in the
graph and you can use those as inputs to
machine learning so what are these that
these two you see that all these use
cases have in common
well the first thing really comes down
to flexibility one of the things that
graph databases are very good at is
being able to work with your data in a
flexible manner all of these use cases
if you really think about it requires
some level of flexibility not only with
the data that's stored with but how you
look at the data and how you query the
data on the other thing you'll see it
here again connections each of these use
cases really to the heart of it get down
to think how the data is connected more
than the data itself but if you're
skeptic and you're skeptic like I am you
say I can do all that stuff and sequel
I've been doing this stuff in sequel for
years you know I always like this
analogy of you know if the only tool is
a hammer everything looks like a nail
this you know that kind of you know the
relational database is that hammer and
in most cases it does just fine but
there's two specific use cases here I
kind of wanted to call out that where
graph databases are definitely work
better than a relational database and
this kind of comes back to that and what
I said initially where there's two real
use things I like to think about in
graph databases is being able to do
something an other tool does better and
being able to do something another tool
can't really do and on the one where I
want we're going to talk a little bit
about where it can do graph databases
work better than other tools is
recursive queries I mean recursive
queries I don't know how how many people
here have ever had to write recursive
CGEN sequel server how many people
actually like Rakitic writing recursive
CTS and sequel server yeah there if
you've never had to do it you're very
lucky I find them very complicated to
get correct they end up being very hard
to maintain and you're DBAs are probably
not going to be your best fans if you
have to write any complex one of these
because they end up being resource hogs
that tend to be
be tough to performance-tuned well why
is that well part of that is just the
nature of the way that a sequel server
works you know sequel servers use be
trees under the cover to basically be
able to store an index or data and be
trees are very very good at indexing
data and being able to retrieve that
data efficiently they're not necessarily
as good as being able to find
connections between data graph databases
on the other hand use a data structure
from graph theory known as an adjacency
list adjacency list basically when it
comes right down to it is essentially a
linked list saying this vertex is
connected to this vertex via this edge
well that data structure allows for
being able to quickly traverse edges
from one vertex to another which is
basically in the end whatever cursive
query really wants to do you're trying
to recurse across those connections in
order to find your data so if you want
to look at some simple example let's
look at an employee hierarchy well if
you have the employee hierarchy it's
gonna look something like this and I
want to maybe say I want to find out how
I you know what is the reporting path
from myself down there in the bottom
corner to the CEO well if I'm gonna do
it in sequel it's gonna end up looking
something like this this is you know not
necessarily the most fun to read not
necessarily the most fun to figure out
and probably not necessarily gonna be
the most performant option so if I
wanted to do it in graph it looks like
this this the query ends up being
significantly simpler to look at what
you're looking at here is one of the
graph query languages that's out there
called gremlin we'll talk about that
here in a minute and then to be honest
about half of that gremlin query is
really just being able to form out the
data to come out and okay you want the
other one I wanted to talk about is to
be able to you know an example of when
you can do something in a graph database
that's not easily done in others but
this brings us to the kind of concept of
a path a path on the graph database is
pretty is a pretty unique data structure
because a path and a graph database not
only says what that two things are
connected but it gives you the sequence
of vertices and edges you need to go
across in order to get from one to
another so in this example if we wanted
to find the path from Alice to Bob
there's actually two paths the first
path is the red arrow so there would be
a path from Alice and then that red
arrow that red
that's as follows to Bob it also be a
second path which would be from Alice
across that follows edge to Ted and
across that follows edge back to Bob so
that's basically what a path is but how
do you use it well I like to use this
riddle this riddle of the river crossing
problem I don't know if that's common
this river crossing comm problem is
common here in Europe but it is in the
US so the river crossing problem is you
have a farmer that's got a fox a goat
and some carrots you can only take one
of them across a river at a specific
time but there's a couple of constraints
he can't leave the Fox with the goat
because if you leave a Fox the goat that
goats gonna be eaten he can't leave the
go with the carrots for the same reason
if you leave the goat with the carrots
that goats gonna be eaten so what it
comes down to is this really comes down
to a constraint problem you end up with
you know you end up with a current state
where everything's on one side of the
river what you have three potential
state changes you can go across you can
bring across the goat in which case you
you're at a valid state and you bring
across the carrots you're in an invalid
state or if you bring across the Fox
you're in an invalid state so this is
one example where I you know as far as
like to do this in a sequel this is not
exactly an easy thing to do you know
constraint optimization problems are
definitely not something that are a lot
of fun to try and handle in most most
existing technologies there's a lot of
brute force that has to go into trying
to make those works so what if it what
if your database could help you solve
these problems well a graph database can
help you solve these sorts of problems
by this so to model this what we do is
we'd start out by modeling the current
state of everything inside our graph
just for this example the T stands for
the boat the F stands for the Fox the G
stands for the goat and the C stands for
the carrots the underscore is which side
of the river it's on its gonna get a
little confusing but that can't make it
too big and still fit it all on a slide
sort of problem so you end up modeling
that so you end up with an initial state
model it is a vertex well the next step
is to model all your state changes well
you can model your state changes as the
relationship between a current state in
a future state so if you do this case
you can take you know you can model
those three potential state changes and
you'll see that if you take the carrots
it's going to lead you in an Val
State which I've colored here in red you
take the goose it's gonna leave you to a
valid state and if you take the Fox it's
gonna lead you to an invalid state so
now you take that and you do the same
thing again and you just repeat this and
I end up with you know two options I can
either take a GU I can either take the
goose back on the boat in which case I
return back to my exist a previous state
or I can take return empty in which case
I move to a new state if I do this for
all of the potential options I end up
with a graph that looks like this
so if I take a look at this graph and I
want to figure out how to you know how
to actually answer the question well to
do that I'm gonna simplify it down a
little bit I'm gonna take out any of the
invalid edges or any of the edges that
lead to an invalid State because we know
we can't get there and I'm gonna take
any of the edges out that basically
return back to a previous state because
then you're just gonna end up in a cycle
inside of a graph when I do that I get
this well this comes down to I think we
can all pretty much easily see that
there's two potential paths through this
graph well how do I query yet if I want
to answer this question if I want to
answer this question this is all I have
to do to be able to answer this this is
an example where you know I I run the
query like this and then I can get my
results back out like this so what
you'll notice is a couple of things one
it was a pretty easy query in a graph
database to be able to answer a
constraint type problem and second that
not only do I get that these two things
are related or that there's two paths
but I get how those two things are
related what is the series of steps I
have to do to get from one state from a
desired state to an end State well this
is just a riddle this doesn't seem like
a real life problem but I've used this
same concept before to handle supply
chain optimization problems maybe you
have a maybe you have a set of
warehouses and a set of deliveries that
need to be made to a set of stores well
there's going to be a multiple different
ways you can actually do this well if
you if you model it as a graph you can
come up especially if you modeled as a
graph and you put weights on the
different potential options maybe you
prefer to ship it via rail versus via
truck or via our plane versus via rail
you can come up with essentially a set
of weighted options that tells you what
are the potential solutions to your
problem what are the potential solutions
to a constraint type problem and it's
something I've actually seen used pretty
effectively to be a
to model these sorts of what-if
scenarios because you know while you may
not use MIT while it may not give you
just the one answer but it will present
your users with a variety of options
that they can use in order to say yeah I
want to go with I want to go with option
B not option C or an option A so how do
you know how do you know if you have a
graph problem I like to look at these
kind of for questions and they're
basically ranked in order of importance
as far as I'm concerned with the most
important one being at the top the first
most important question is really do you
care about the relationships between
entities more than the entities
themselves if you do that's usually a
really classically good example of a
problem that what graph database is
likely to help you be able to solve the
second one is if you were to model this
in a relational system it are usually
gonna take multiple joins or recursive
CT ease in order to answer it well the
reason this question is in there is
basically it in my experience if you
need to do this sort of complex modeling
where you need to do multiple joints and
you need to do recursive CT ease inside
a relational the database to do it that
tends to lead to the fact that you
really care more about how that could
data is connected then the actual
entities itself because you're doing
that multiple joining that recursion in
order to traverse the connections
between them to in order to migrate
across those different connections is
your data in your questions continuously
evolving one of the features flag that
we mentioned a little bit earlier is the
flexibility of graph database it's the
flexibility of them to not only answer
different questions to look at data in
different ways but also to be able to
query them in multiple different ways
that aren't necessarily that are a
little more flexible than some of the
the ways that you can query relational
databases in last which is probably to
me the we the weakest of these questions
is is your domain a natural fit for a
graph if your domain that you're working
in is a natural fit for graph just
because it's a natural fit for graph if
the questions you're asking aren't a
natural fit for a graph then it isn't
probably a good graph use case but if it
is in one of those good use cases we
talked about it may lead you towards
looking at that question a little bit
more or that that you use case a little
bit more to really see if you were
actually just missing something
so where to start where do you start
when you're gonna go build something on
the graph database well if you start
like me and pretty much everybody else
in the world your google it and if you
google graph database vendors you have a
problem it's really confusing because
the graph database landscape is growing
it's huge and it's confusing
specifically so that this slide was
actually made by a graph consulting
company earlier this year called graph
where and it's out of date already it
was at a date when they published it but
even since I put it on this slide about
two weeks ago I know at least two new
graph databases that come on the market
since then so it's really hard to know
to where to even start because there's
so many options the graph database space
especially when you compare it to a lot
of the other no sequel database spaces
is very immature especially if you
compare it to a relational database
space it's very immature there's not a
lot of standards out there there isn't
you know as clear a set of winners or a
clear set of losers so what I like to do
is I try to bucket things into a I'm a
BA I'm a lumper I like to try to lump
things together to at least give me a
place to start looking well I kind of
came up with three different buckets
that I tend to look at these tools at
and the first one being it's a graph
computing engine so when I think of it
when I think of something as a graph
computing engine what it really comes
down to is it's a library it's a library
that I bring into my code into my
project to work with mainly the main
feature I see when that puts it into
this versus a database per se is that
really these sorts of frameworks and
features only handle data processing
they don't handle the persistence of the
data they're not there to basically
store the data and retrieve the data
they're just there to run graph
algorithms on top of the data this means
you have to use something like a
relational database or CSV es or some
other data source to populate that up
run your algorithms on potentially store
the data back into and this is really
optimized for a couple of use cases and
they in the big use cases are things
like I want to run background processes
on graph data this is a great use case
you don't necessarily have to bring a
whole bunch of new infrastructure in you
can just add it to into a project you're
working on and you're good to go and
this is also really good for processing
what are known as global graph
properties global graph properties with
types of properties around a graph
something like centrality or influence
that requires you to look at all or most
all of the data in your graph in order
to answer that question the other the
other common characteristic this is
these are usually built around frame
around other frameworks and usually a
lot of big data processing frameworks
something like Hadoop or spark these are
usually built quite often these are
built to run on those or built into
those to do those to do these sorts of
questions the second one is really the
first of the database types I think of
and that's the RDF triple storm so the
RDF triple store is based on the
Semantic Web it's where it originally
comes from RDF stands for a resource
description framework and it is a w3c
standard about how to describe data for
interconnection and it kind of it's
based on this subject object predicate
model a couple unique characteristics
I've already F triple stores that I
always look forward so in RDF triple
store each property is going to be
stored as as fast as a specific vertex
in your graph so if you had a in a
relational relational world if you had a
table that had one row of data in for in
five columns or sorry four columns you
would end up with five vertices in your
in your graph with four edges connecting
them as the example kind of shows up
here you know we have a flight there's a
cost associated a to a--from and the
amount of money the second big feature
of these and actually worth where they
derive a lot of their power is they have
what's known as an inference engine so
you set you put in these triples you put
in these triples and then you put in
essentially rules of route about your
data so you can put in different rules
about the data this inference engine
will then run on top of it and be able
to create new relationships based on
those rules and that's really one of the
that's what these are really optimized
for us to be able to infer new
relationships and data for things you
didn't necessarily know you had the
second type of database is the one I'm
used the most often and that's what's
known as a labeled property graph these
are probably I would say potentially
depends on you ask but they could be you
know they're probably the more popular
one that's out there certainly if you
google this is probably the first one
you're going to come out
the label property graphs and these are
based on vertices edges and properties
these are probably the most similar to a
relational databases of any of these
that the concepts so you have vertices
which represent the entities in your
data you have edges which represent the
relationships and then you have
properties and those properties
represent the attributes on your data
and those properties are stored as key
value pairs on top of both vertices and
edges that's one of the kind of the
distinct differences between a
relational database and a graph database
is the ability for those edges to have
rich metadata associated with them
themselves I like to think of them as in
relation in a graph database
relationships are first-class citizens
just like for just like the vertices are
and these really come down to labelled
property graphs are really optimized for
traversing known relationships they're
really optimized for being able to
traverse across patterns of data or you
know patterns in your graph that you are
that you already know exist so they're
not is so if you want to deal with
inference more you go towards the rdf
side if you want to do towards reversals
more i find the labeled property graphs
to be a little more better answer but
unfortunately just like everything else
in the world the buckets aren't as clean
as one would hope you know you end up
with an overlapping Venn diagram of how
these things work I mean I work for data
stacks and our even data stacks
enterprise graph the one that I work
with all the time it's both a computing
engine and a labeled property graph so
that none of you know there's not as
necessarily as clean a distinction as
one would hope between the different
types of databases so it does get very
confusing but what's even more confusing
is query languages one of the things I
attribute to some of the in maturity in
the space is the fact that there isn't a
single query language for graph
databases there's many query languages
for graph databases and many graph
databases support more than one graph in
query language so it gets very complex
the there isn't a way there is a effort
undergoing right now to try and
standardize query languages especially
across labelled property graphs but at
best that's going to it's going through
isit you know it's it's just starting
the ISO process so it's going to be
several years before there's
any solid agreement on what's going on
so this is another confusion but what it
really comes down to is one sheet if you
choose your database that will really
dictate the query language you can use
but before you run away if I haven't
scared you off yet I'm glad before you
want away let's talk about my mistakes a
little bit hopefully you can learn from
my mistakes so you don't repeat them and
the first mistake that I make I've made
before and I see customers make all the
time is really understand what you're
looking for in your data one of the
things that people will do is they'll
put all their information in a graph and
then all of a sudden just somehow think
magic is gonna happen and they're gonna
get insight back out you still have to
know what questions you want to ask you
have to understand what that question
means is that question going you know
you know is that question going to take
you take is that question going to
require that you to look at all the data
in your graph well if it's gonna look at
require you to look at all the data in
your graph to answer this question
you're probably not gonna get a response
back in ten in 20 or 30 milliseconds and
they say yeah you laugh but I've seen
people definitely think that that's the
case on the other hand is it gonna look
at it it's gonna look a really small
subset which is known as a sub graph of
your data in which case you might be
able to get responses back very quickly
so really understand what it is you're
looking for and what that question
you're asking on takes to actually be
able to answer is one of the areas where
I've seen people trip up frequently
second one is understand what your tool
is doing I mean this looks like a
harmless little query doesn't it this
looks like what you probably would write
you know right after the first time you
try to do it well this is the equivalent
sequel to do it which for those of you
that can't see what you have to do so
what that quote book query is doing is
it's getting a count of every vertex in
a graph so what you'd have to do the
equivalent sequel would basically be to
create a temporary table then loop over
every table in your relational database
find the count of it insert it into a
temporary table and then do a sum on
that who's going to run that in
production who's whose DBA is not gonna
kill them for running that in the
production system but I've seen people
run that for that graph query on a
production system and wonder why it's
slow why the graph slows down to a halt
so really understanding what it is that
you're actually asking of the tool is
really important
next understand what your algorithm is
that you're doing well you know there's
lots of different graph algorithms out
there and there's lots of interesting
things you can do with them I mean if
you wanted to do something like as a
vertex or an edge look up that's a
straight that's a linear time question
that that's a very quick thing if you
want to do a degree or the number of
edges associated with a vertex that's
also pretty quick things but you know
what those don't tend to be the most
interesting things you want to do with
the graph because you can do those with
a relational database or a key value
database or any other database out there
you want to start looking at some of the
interesting things you can do with the
graph they start getting complex or they
get start to get computationally complex
you know you want to look at a shortest
path algorithm or you know what is the
shortest path between two vertices in
our graph well that's at the best case
is an O to the N squared you know you
want to do a PageRank so that the famous
influence algorithm that Google created
you want to run that on a graph that's
an O to the n plus M with N and M being
the number of vertices and edges so you
quickly see if you try to run a PageRank
on a billion node of a billion vertex
graph it's not going to be very quick
it's gonna take a lot of computation in
order to answer that you want to look at
something like a chromatic number which
if you don't know what a chromatic
number is that's a really interesting
graph thing unfortunately they'll have
time to go into it today or an allpass
Algrim you're talking about NPR and key
hard and np-complete problems you know
I've worked with customers that have
said I want to run all pass algorithm
and I wanted to return on a billion node
graph and I wanted to return in seconds
well that's just not realistic so
understanding what your algorithm is
going to do and how complex it is is
really important to be able to set
realistic expectations second one is or
the other the next one is understand
your data we work with customers all the
time that don't take the time to really
understand what the complexity is within
the data they're trying to work on the
one that kind of tends to bite you all
the time in a graph is what's known as
branching factor so the branching factor
of a graph is the number of successors
for any for any node so if you have a
branching factor of two that means one
node if
traverse out an edge it'll be two nodes
and then it'd be four nodes branch
factor threes one two three to nine
branch factor four is one to four to
sixteen which doesn't seem like a big
deal until you start less saying I just
maybe maybe my data it doesn't have a
branch factor of two it's got a
branching factor of six well if you want
to do a branching factor six and you
want to go out six levels deep that
means you're touching fifty something
like fifty six thousand vertices in
order to get there it's it's a very
complex problem so understanding what
your data looks like is really critical
in order to be able to yet again set
realistic expectations of what you can
do the other part that of this of
understand your data is understanding
what the tails are understand what the
tails of your distribution are and how
frequent those are we were working with
one customer where most of their data
was fine most of their customers had no
problem however they were trying to do
you know they were trying to do a
look-up on an address that look up on
the address for specific Uppal of
specific customers had 50,000 edges
associated with it so there's 50,000
people associated with a specific
address excuse me
address the data was actually valid
because my first thought was like
everybody else here who wins just like
that doesn't seem right it was actually
valid but you know being able to
understand that that was a problem in
being able to mitigate that upfront
would have been something that would
have helped because it ended up being it
wasn't until we got to testing and
testing on real data that we understand
leer an in to that sort of problem this
all just seems too complicated
don't worry there are ways you can be
successful with your graph project I
know I asked that question earlier and
there weren't many hands that got raised
as far as how who had successful graph
projects but there are successful ways
to do it so how can you be successful
well the first way is be prepared to
think different don't think that you can
take your relational methodology of how
you think about a problem for a
relational database and just apply to a
graph and it's gonna work there's a
fundamental mind shift you have to take
when you're going from a relational
database month mindset to a graph
database mindset in a relational
database mindset relational databases
are based on set theory and when they're
based on set theory they really have an
entity first thought about how you will
look at your data and how you model your
data you really think what are the
things in my data and then you figure
out how things are related in a graph
database it's based on graph theory and
graph theory is all about relationships
so you
have to kind of transform over to having
a relationship first mindset you have to
really start thinking about the
relationships in your data more than you
think about the entities in your data
because graphs are all about
relationships and the relationships are
what's important if the relationships
aren't what's important don't use a
graph databases is my advice be prepared
that the tooling isn't going to be what
you want there's no such thing as a link
to graph there's no sign you know the
tools are inmature the the tooling is
not gonna be what you want it's not what
you're used to from working with the
relational databases it's getting there
it's improving but it's young you know
relational databases have had 30 or 40
years to figure out all the different
flaws and features graph databases in
realistic terms have been around maybe
eight so we still have a lot of growing
to do in order to actually get to the
point where we have the same level of
seamless tooling so it's not going to be
a seamless transition when if you're
trying to work with a graph database
second is choose the right tool I mean
who thinks that's the right way to use a
drill press I'm at I'm actually
impressed that that guy can hold it up
choosing a tool just because it's
available as dangerous we've all done
this myself included we've used a
relational database because it's there
or we've used the graph databases
because it's there but my experience
especially when you start getting with
any complex sort of sort of problem or
any complex sort of data layer is
there's usually multiple different
shapes of data you need to be able to
handle you need to be able to handle key
value data pairs you need to be able to
work here in a relational you need to
handle a graph and you need to be able
to choose the right tool to solve the
part of the job that you're working on
it adds some complexity in as much as
now you have different problems you have
to solve with data being stored in
different areas and two-phase commits
and all those things nobody'll it really
likes to talk about but when it comes
down to it in my experience it's still
usually the right way to approach most
of the problems because you saw you
introduced certain problems but you
solve other problems working in
bite-sized chunks this is one that
shouldn't need to be said but seems to
always get forgotten and pretty much
every graph project I mean who wants to
start using new technology and all of a
sudden try to do everything with it well
that's what people constantly
to do in graph databases so don't try to
boil the ocean you know you use common
sense just start with a small project a
specific silo of our project and just
use it to develop a reusable pattern
don't try and say I'm gonna rewrite this
entire application on a graph even
though you've never built anything on a
graft in your life it's probably not
going to be a successful way to look at
a problem and then play off for failure
like any new technology you're not going
to get it right the first time these
aren't necessarily the you know this
isn't necessarily the easiest transition
that you have to make not only is it an
infrastructure transition it's a query
language transition it's a mindset
transition it's an operational
transition assuming you're gonna get
that all right the very first time isn't
gonna happen so planning time for
experimentation plan in time to make
sure that you can get this right and
have a back-up plan because you know
what more often than not I've had to
pull the ripcord on it and actually go
with a back-up plan then then then I
should have say I have to do that more
often enough likes to admit because
there were just ended up being too many
complications with trying to go down
this route so watch for the warning
signs this is some examples of some of
the the warning signs that I look for on
projects that I've either experienced
personally or I've worked with clients
or colleagues have worked with clients
that have run into bad warning signs
choosing as a graph is the solution
before you understand the problem this
is very interesting cuz I was actually
in a ml talk this morning where she said
the exact same thing she doesn't want to
go into projects where they've already
decided they need to use machine
learning to solve it because they how do
you know you even need to use machine
learning to solve it if you don't know
what the problem is make sure you
understand the business problem and then
evaluate whether graphs the right tool
writing your own graph database in a
framework while there are a few
companies out there that are smart
enough to write their own graph database
and framework most aren't most people
don't have the time or expertise to be
able to go and write their own graph
database and framework so use the ones
are out there those ones have been
tested those ones have been tested by
multiple different people in multiple
different scenarios and they've already
run into them for all the problems that
you would run into so just use one of
them going back to what I said just a
minute ago is trying to write a complete
do a complete rewrite of everything just
use
Graff just saying all of a sudden we're
just gonna use a graph for everything
because now graphs are cool and they're
fun and we want to use them over
confidence in your graph abilities I've
never built on a graph database before
but I'm sure I'll get it right the first
time these are the sort of projects you
just want to run away from run as fast
as you can yellow light projects these
are ones where a cut where you know the
project maybe maybe okay but we're not
sure yet these are the ones where
there's been a little too understanding
of the chosen tool they've decided that
they're going to use this because it was
the first thing that came up on Google
this is the first answer they came up on
Google so we're just gonna use that one
to solve all our problems we're not
gonna do the the work required to figure
out if it's the right tool for the
problem nobody on your team has any
graph experience nobody's ever tried to
use a graph database before but you're
gonna do it lack of schema enforcement I
didn't really mention this before but
one of the things that most graph
databases have is skeet oh well not all
graph databases have a schema some graph
databases explicitly define schema much
like a relational database in which case
schema enforcement's pretty easy schema
enforcement's done at the database level
you can't add a property to a ground to
a vertex that doesn't exist on the other
hand there's a lot of them when you do
the research because essentially
properties are key value pairs they're
called schema less so they allow they
allow queries to add whatever properties
they want to a graph as they're going
through or whatever labels whatever they
looking for this tends to be a problem
though because if you order sudden have
five different things five different
properties being added to different
parts of the graph with different names
because different developers are
choosing it this tends to be you know
end up with something that's first name
in full name and last name and they're
spelled differently and they all show up
is different key pairs so now your
queries to be able to pull back
realistic or reasonable data become
horrendous so you need to see invoice a
schema if it's not explicitly done at
the database level then you need to
implicitly do it at the application
level and the other one which I've
personally experienced is working on
projects when there's no when you don't
have ops or DevOps support both I mean
your ops and anybody in office and
DevOps needs to be brought into this
process as early as possible in order
for that to be successful because if you
don't much like you there it's a new
tool they need to learn they need to
bring be up be brought up to speed on
how this
going to affect their daily today their
day-to-day workflow how they're going to
need to be able to manage this and
handle it going forward so you need to
bring these in you need to bring them in
as early as possible in order to be
successful these are the projects where
they're just kind of teetering on the
edge you can still pull them back to be
successful or you cannot they and then
there's a projects we all want to be on
these are the ones unfortunately the
rare few but these are the ones where
they're starting small you're spending
time you're choosing the right tool
you're building in time for the team to
learn because it's a learning process I
mean we're all developers we all love to
learn so I mean that's why we're all
here right we all want to learn and
these are the ones that have the plan
for failure they have they have the
executive buy-in to know that this may
not work so we may have to fall back to
a different way of solving the same
problem these are the ones we all really
want to be on and these are the ones
where we love to get to so if I haven't
scared you away so far and you want to
get started with a graph database I got
a few suggestions first if you have an
afternoon if you have an afternoon you
can go download we basically data stacks
just release this tool data stacks
desktop it's still an experimental mode
but it works basically you can go
download it and within a minute or two
it'll be you'll be up and running in a
docker eyes din vironment containing our
database and our IDE tool which is a
web-based tool you can go in there you
can click on explore traversals with DSC
graph and you can start getting work oh
you can start working away with graphs
very very quickly you know have some fun
learn some gremlin as my one friend said
you do this on a Friday afternoon open a
bottle of wine and by the end of the
afternoon one of the two things will be
finished you'll either be done with your
traversal you'll be done with your wine
either way you've had a good afternoon
if you have a few days if you have a few
days you know find some of your own data
load it up CSVs are pretty easy to get
into most graph databases load them up
start running to writing some of your
own traversal start taking some of the
information you've learned and make and
find something interesting you know
maybe start running some of those
recursive and pathfinding queries see
what you can find in your data maybe run
some analytics on that find some
distributions find what your data looks
like inside a graph to be able to you
know start down that path if you have a
couple of weeks if you have a couple of
weeks to play around you're pretty lucky
but sometimes people get it
but this is where you can start really
digging in this is where you can start
spending time learning the text art not
just learning the high level of what a
graphs are how graphs work but start
learning of so many underlying features
and functionality graphs how they work
how they store data why when to use them
when not to use them the other thing
I've seen worked very successfully for
people is take this time solve a
business a problem that has business
value run some graph analytics find some
clusters influence maybe find some of
those hidden insights that are not
necessarily available to your to your
business right now if you can build if
you have time build a sample application
I've actually successfully seen people
do this where they've be able to present
this to management and it's actually
gotten them promotions raises and things
of that nature because they were able to
actually show the bid the value of what
they were doing they weren't just
sitting there playing they were able to
show the value behind what they were
doing
so summarized graphs or highly optimized
to deal with highly connected data types
connections in the data are where it's
matters for graphs and they do and
they're able to use this to help provide
insight into information in your data in
the in specifically information the
connections in your data they can't
easily be seen in other ways but be
careful because working with graph
projects requires a different mindset
and you need to approach it a little
different than you're used to in order
to be successful so kind of conclusions
I think graphs are great for two main
reasons first one is they're great for
solving problems you can't necessarily
solve with existing tech you know this
is the river crossing problem these are
the sorts of constraint problem you know
this constraint optimization problems
that you can't easily do with existing
tech that's Tanz out there today the
second one is to be able to solve
problems you can you can solve today but
differently and maybe more optimally
this is the whole hierarchy recursive
sort of scenario but I do leave it as
last one last word of warning
they aren't magic don't think you can
throw data in a graph and all of a
sudden everything is going to be perfect
make sure you had that you have the
right problem to fit them hopefully this
trucks giving you a bit of a guide as to
what some of the right problems are and
some of the things to look for last
thing I'd ask you if you want to [ __ ]
please follow me on Twitter
also by my book the shameless plug for
purchasing my book that's the link right
there and actually that code underneath
there I think is good for another week
and that's good for I believe any
Manning book it's 40% off any Manning
book not just my book so maybe if you
not interested so much in my book but
you want to read a book by any of the
other Manning authors here or on any
other subjects please feel free to go
out and use it
lastly I think I have a couple of
minutes left are there any questions
yeah so the question was how do you
scale graph databases
well how you scale graph databases sort
of depends on which graph database you
choose for example I work for data sex
enterprise graph and ours is by Nate by
its very nature a linear scalable graph
database because it's built on top of
Cassandra so it's built it's it's
already built on a distributed
foundation so the question was in
specifically on Cassandra since um when
I brought up was how do you how do you
partition the data out and shard the
data out in a way that actually works
for graph databases is that affair okay
just make sure I summarized it correctly
well the answer is that comes down to a
lot of data modeling that you have to do
and specifically in Cassandra there's a
thing called the partition key that you
have to work on basically figuring out
the most optimal way to be able to
cluster those data that you're going to
request are you going to Traverse
together into a single node or a single
set of nodes it actually becomes a bit
when you start talking about
distributing just like when you talk to
start talking about distributing any
database there becomes a lot of data
modeling questions and data modeling
trade-offs you have to make yeah so so
for specifically I mentioned
specifically in data stacks enterprise
what you have to do is you when you
create it has explicit access explicit
schema and when you create that explicit
schema you specify what field you're
going to partition on that data is then
part
and under the covers you can still
traverse across partitions but obviously
if you're a petition if you're if you're
traversing across network hops it's
obviously going to be slower than if
you're traversing inside the same the
same memory space any other questions
yes yes so so the statement was what I
said was that both nodes and edges can
have properties attached to it yeah
that's actually a very that's actually a
very very good question the question was
how do you how do you decide what is
represented as a node what is
represented as an edge um
what represents a node in an edge is a
little bit easier than what represents a
property or a vertex so so usually when
you when you do data modeling for a
graph specifically for label property
graphs you tend to think of the the
vertices are represented represent the
nouns in your in your data model and the
edges represent the verbs so the actions
tend to be represent the relationships
between things so like flight two in
this case would be the vert the verb
between those two now where you put
properties in what becomes a property
and what becomes a vertex is actually a
very complex thing and usually that
comes down to how are you going to query
the data because you can put everything
out as a property or you can put
everything either usually either as a
property or as a vertex so for example
pilots you could have pilots as both a
propper as a property on the flight too
or you could have it as a vertex it
really comes down to how you're going to
query that data back out in order to
kind of know that the other thing you
can do which is really common is if
you're gonna is you put it in both
places you end up denormalizing a lot in
graphs it's not the optimal way to do it
in from a graph the
perspective but it does end up being the
pragmatic answer that you have to do
much like you know everybody yeah third
normal form would be great in relational
databases but how many date relational
databases only have third normal form
so does that that answer your question a
little bit yeah I mean it
the answer is it's it's hard there's not
a there's not a simple to ants to minute
answer if you want feel free to hit me
up afterwards we can talk about any more
depth if you want any other questions
right well thank you everyone for coming
to my talk
thanks to NDC Oslo for having me